hello you're playing the waiting game
North Korea's most popular gaming
recommendation show before it went
behind that Iron Curtain paywall I'm
sorry friends but do not weep for me
it's your loss not mine today we're
alone on a ship drifting through space
looking at alien isolation the survival
horror title isn't you out until late
2014 so plenty of time to sink your
angry tongue mouth into something
intriguingly similar for example alien
isolation is being produced by the nice
folks at sega sega also made Sonic the
Hedgehog but sonic is blue which is the
same color as Isaac Clarke's health bar
in dead space which is our first
recommendation oh my god faster the
better I hear something crawling around
out there it's the classic tale of boy
meets alien alien eats boy Isaac Clarke
is a humble engineer sent aboard a
mining vessel that's gone dark the crew
is missing but the ship is crawling with
monstrous creatures called necromorphs
all isaac has is an assortment of
engineering tools to defend himself with
which conveniently decapitate all things
biology while Isaac is no SAP is also no
muscle clad ultra soldier your health is
limited and your ammunition scarce
making the prospect of coming up against
the necromorph all the more terrifying
alien isolation features just one alien
in the entire game and while you will be
facing off against non-alien adversaries
the knowledge that it's always hunting
you makes the fear just that little bit
more raw so for the feeling of crippling
loneliness vulnerability and your
inevitable death aboard a desolate ship
go on a saga cruise and play dead space
Jesus just right for finding your own
space now if you were trapped on an
island full of dinosaurs there's only
one person you'd want by your side right
too close for me well did you know you
can have him in space to just come back
while it's not strictly about an alien
species Alan Grant and Morpheus filter
still managed to find a load of Horrors
in the deep vacuum of our galaxy event
horizon tells the story of a group of
Astro science chums who've traveled to
the edge of the solar system to find a
lost ship with an experimental gravity
Drive the event horizon has the unique
ability to create wormholes and jump
from point to point after all that's one
big pile of space not even Samuels line
I know that is one big pile of [ __ ] but
when the ship fails to appear at the
other end you and the crew are left
wondering where it could have possibly
travel to before mysteriously appearing
again and of course it means that
something awful has to happen to the
folks on board after all space will find
a way now it may seem like an obvious
choice but the film alien is exactly
what you need to have under your belt
before playing isolation and I do mean
the first one the 1979 Ridley Scott
alien is a true horror compared to the
action romp of James Cameron's aliens
the film also introduces you to Ellen
Ripley whose daughter Amanda you'll be
playing in isolation when Ellen goes
missing as a psychological horror Ridley
Scott also took influences from such
classics as 2001 Space Odyssey star wars
a new hope and even the texas chainsaw
massacre which by the way we recommended
a few episodes back with the evil within
if gore and horror is your bag as well
as space and aliens go watch it after
isolation perfectly recreates the
knife-edge terror of sharing your living
quarters with a big nasty and you will
end up feeling a real kinship for the
ill-fated crew of the Nostromo and even
the original cast who often wouldn't be
warned of certain shock devices used in
scenes it's great to spot some fine
attention to detail in the game play
previews of isolation be at the include
of particular props or the adoption of
sounds from the film they really do tie
together nicely if you're going to
appreciate the design of isolation it's
only polite to acknowledge the master
designer of the alien itself kurt geiger
listen i was going to make a kurt geiger
HR giger joke and then i found this so
that's terrifying Hans Rudolf Geiger is
the man you can thank for coming up with
the iconic alien design he's a Swiss
surrealist whose team won the Academy
Award for visual effects for their
design on the original alien film the
book Geiger's alien tells the whole
story of its conception and the months
of work that went into making the film
look quite so terrifying and if you're
not satisfied by all the previous
interstellar and interdimensional travel
how about warping back to the 90s and
visiting gigas website you could buy a
chair whilst you're at it also he
designed that ridiculous mic stand for
corn well this last suggestions a little
left field but why not check out Outkast
the Atlanta Georgia hip-hop duo
responsible for such classic hits as
miss Jackson lost and hey yeah outlast
outlast it's a much better suited
recommendation because alien isolation
is set in space not stankonia which is a
made-up place and a good shout if you
like to crap your pants whilst gaming
like a typical Saturday night for myself
you're armed with just a video camera
upon tional for darkness at an
insatiable sense of curiosity outlast
drops you into an asylum where you must
navigate your surroundings without
having any real form of combat to fall
back on you'll instead have to use
lockers beds and anything else you can
find to effectively hide yourself while
enemies are nearby now alien isolation
uses the same mechanic with your
interstellar adversary using smell and
sight to find you while also learning
your patterns of evading capture our
last is only about a month out of the
box so it also looks the business too
you can pick it up for ps4 and PC right
now Rhino a few more pointers before I
let you get back to we
it's okay my children don't rush out and
buy gearboxes aliens colonial Marines
because it's not very good why not play
hide and seek it's arguably the cheapest
and you can always make it more alien by
giving the hunter a cup of sulfuric acid
and a bat to bind you with for legal
purposes I am required to point out that
was a joke don't throw acid on your
friends don't forget to check out our
waiting game for the evil within which
has a bunch of other awesome horror
suggestions or cams reality check on why
we just love to be scared to death
isolation will be out at the end of the
year but hopefully these recommendations
will keep your fear glands full until
you can go up against history's most
dangerous a cunning hunter the majestic
space Raptor hey Ames do Greg I'm gonna
level with you I've only ever seen
Jurassic Park